MARISSA GIUSTINA: Hello.
I'm Marissa Giustina,
and I'd like
to introduce you to a
new series of videos
about quantum computers
and how to program them.
We have a series of
four videos covering
a broad set of concepts
we think you'll enjoy.
I'll explain what quantum
computing actually is.
It's rather different from
traditional computing,
and there are lots of narratives
out there describing it.
I'll boil it down
to the essentials,
show you how quantum computers
work and how they can be used.
Daniel will dig
into the differences
between classical and
quantum information
on a physical level.
You'll learn about
traditional memory
and how it works on a
micro electronic level,
then build on this to see
how a quantum chip works.
Next will come the programming
of a quantum computer,
and Dave will tell
you all about it,
not just the concepts and
programming a quantum computer
but also the new and
open-source Cirq language that
makes it easy.
Then finally, if you're
interested in the deep concepts
of computer science,
Sergio has a treat for you.
He'll talk about the
long-established strong
Church-Turing thesis and how
quantum computing provides
an exciting breakthrough
from the limitations
of traditional computing.
This is the first
set of videos we're
producing for Google
Developers, and we'd
love to hear your
feedback on them.
If you have any questions for me
or any of the other presenters,
please leave them in
the comments box below.